I don't think that the legislation was passed definitively in the interest of
putting more black people in jail. That's what it did,
but I don't think Joe Biden was sitting in a room legislating like, hell yeah,
he's black. And for sure.
With the election upon us,
millions of Americans are gearing up to cast their vote for the next president
of the United States. While some people will be voting independent.
We want it to hear from Trump voters and Biden voters about why they are voting
for their candidate in spectrum.
We bring everyday people together for authentic discussions that represent
what's happening. Now,
these discussions should not be anyone sole source forming opinions on important
issues. Please do your own research, seek out experts,
push yourself outside your bubble and have empathy. Thanks for watching.
My name is Christina.
And I am 23 years old and I live in Houston, Texas.
I think that the overall civic health of America is just so low.
And I feel like the more we have these kinds of conversations,
the more people will start to think for them.
Hi, I'm Piper. I'm passionate about decolonization,
systemic equality,
socialism and environmentalism name is [inaudible].
I'm currently a freshman at the university of Texas at Austin.
It's one of the most consequential elections of our lifetime.
It's going to determine the future of our country and civil rights,
human rights, the climate, and many other issues across the board.
My name is Leah Talas and I'm an environmental activist and the founder of the
intersectional environmentalist platform. My name is Chris.
I currently live in Santa Barbara, California.
I think that a vote for Joe Biden and this election is a vote with the idea of
prosperity for all in mind. Hi, I'm Benjamin.
I work at the democratic coordinator campaign and I help lead a young Asian
Americans for Biden.
We cannot afford to be anything less than passionate as we fight to protect our
families, our friends, our communities, and our futures.
Anti-Trump than pro Biden.
Strongly agree, but yeah.
Strongly agree. Prinav strongly agree.
Benjamin somewhat disagree. Chris. Strongly agree.
Christine agree.
As much as I like absolutely hate Trump, there has to be like young,
especially young people. Like there needs to be that energy there for Biden.
Like I know settle for Biden is huge. Like, well,
we'll take him cause there's two choices. No,
this is like literally a choice between like destruction of the
environment and our futures or building towards better progress.
We have to be more enthusiastic and we have to bring other people along because
otherwise, like we're not going to win.
Definitely agree with what you just said, uh, Benjamin. But at the same time,
like I can't deny like Joe Biden himself does not make me
respond. Enthusiastically.
Like I volunteered for the candidate I supported in the primary is the first
time had ever done it. And it was because I was so I was driven.
Like I feel like I needed to.
At the same time. Um,
I think I would vote for a democratic ticket if it was literally any other
democratic candidate. I understand the enthusiasm Benjamin.
And I think the reason why, like, so I didn't vote.
I voted for Warren in the primary. I was very involved with the campaign. Um,
and like I, if I could put anyone in the white house right now, it'd be her.
But I think like the supporting cast is so important. Like you said,
I'm voting for a better future.
And I don't think that Biden encompasses that entirely.
I think that the entire democratic coalition encompasses that.
Benjamin, you brought up a good point though. Um,
I've like read a bit about like why Hillary Clinton lost in 2016.
And a lot of it was because she ran on a very like anti-Trump campaign because
Hillary Clinton was like a very hated woman.
Like a lot of people just don't like her.
Like I have my reasons for not liking her as well.
And her whole campaign was just like beat Trump, be Trump,
be Trump and a lot of people that wasn't enough for them to get excited behind.
And so you kind of made me like rethink it a little bit,
but I think also though we can't get too excited about him now because we have
to still make sure that there's room for criticism so we can hold him
accountable. Once he actually gets elected.
Joe Biden is too old to be president Piper,
somewhat disagree, disagree, disagree,
Benjamin strongly disagree. Chris disagree,
Christine disagree. Let's say like,
all hell did break loose. And like Joe Biden is now like,
like just suddenly just becomes like cognitively incapable of doing the job.
Kamala Harris. She's a beast. So I mean with the vice presidents for right.
I think the only person who could really say like strongly agree it was is like
a Pete voter. I mean, the person I voted for the primary was also like 70 plus.
So.
His age kind of also fits with his,
like his demeanor or like his appeal. He is more like a,
like a grandfather figure of the like entire party.
That age comes with a lot of experience. And like,
I think right now we need to return to some sort of normalcy.
I also really hate when people pick out a stutter that he's having for like his
whole life, uh, is incredibly able to yeah.
The candidate that I was supporting was older than him and you know,
Trump's old, so it's fine.
I believe abortion is a human right. Piper,
strongly agree. Leah agree. Prinav strong.
Regroup. Benjamin only agree. Chris strongly agree,
Christine. I agree.
I feel like there's a separation of church and state and people just keep
forgetting that. I don't know. I don't know why I'm also,
I don't think anyone like likes abortion and that choice is one that is
incredibly traumatic and hard for I'm sure a lot of people.
And I just really don't like when people are like, well, no abortions,
no sex education, no contraception, no nothing. And it's like,
there's so many other things that would actually help decrease the amount of
abortions that are had. If we could get better sex education in school,
easier access to contraception and healthcare or to abortion is not in the
Bible. Step one, step two. I'm not having an abortion. I don't,
I would never do that. I'm in a situation. And I just that's what I believe,
but that's not my job to enforce that on other people.
And going back to what you said, like sex education,
or why not putting so forth some type of like grant or something.
If people decide not to afford it, why not improving the foster care system?
I mean, they're not giving us any other options.
So you want me to have the baby,
but you're not going to give me anything to support it.
You're not getting improved minimum wage and you're not going to do anything in
my neighborhood to make this safe for my child. So.
What's next first off. I don't believe that life starts at conception.
I do not believe that constitutionally makes sense for a fully grown woman to be
constituted on the same level as a cluster of cells and that they should give
out. Like they shouldn't have to like sacrifice like the right to their bodily
autonomy. The second thing is also, I kind of compare it to like prostitution.
Like it's going to happen to some extent regardless and making it legal and like
having, like having there be like institutions, um,
and like infrastructure for it to be like safe and affordable is a lot better
regardless of whether or not someone thinks that an abortion is good. Um,
you at least want like a woman to be safe.
I think this is one of the biggest reasons to vote for Joe Biden, um,
is because Trump has selected a Supreme court nominee who like
is devout at overturning Roe V. Wade,
if you support autonomy, I think you have to vote for Joe Biden.
Joe Biden has.
A racist past.
I said, agree, somewhat disagree.
Somewhat disagree, Benjamin, somewhat disagree. Chris,
somewhat disagree, Christine.
Um, what disagree? I think there's just goes back to like,
what do we define as racism, but just looking at his policies,
which are kind of the only thing we can go off of like the 1994 crime bill,
like it almost exclusively targeted black Americans.
I know like he also in the Obama administration,
when they had a lot of mass deportations war crimes in the middle East and all
these things put together,
like I can't determine like his individual like opinions,
but all I can go off of is his policies.
And he just has a pretty racist history.
I don't believe that Joe Biden, the person as an individual is a racist man. Um,
but I do think like he has had a history of not making choices that were the
most equitable,
but I also think some of those choices were result of like the cultural
zeitgeist at the time.
And I don't think that Joe Biden necessarily should be held to account for like
the worst parts of that legislation.
Because I don't think that the legislation was passed definitively in the
interest of putting more people in jail.
That's what it did because of the way everything was structured at the time.
Like more black people went to jail,
but I'm hoping Joe Biden was sitting in a room legislating like, hell yeah,
he's black people. For sure, for sure. You know,
even if which I don't believe to be the case at all.
Even if he had like some ball of hatred in his heart against like communities of
color, it's political suicide for him not to help communities of color.
Someone who has worked in the Biden campaign,
like he has plans to help like African-American communities.
He has plans to help like Asian American and Pacific Islander communities.
They're like on his website, like they're part of the platform.
We have like the power to hold them to it and say like,
we elected you to do these things.
Like these are the things you promised us that you would do.
And now we expect you because you voted for you.
Like we expect you to follow through on those promises.
Police department should be defunded Piper,
strongly agree. Leah, strongly agree.
Pranav somewhat agreed. Benjamin I'm on agree.
Chris agree. And Christine somewhat disagree.
I feel like there's not like if we were to defund the police,
now there's not structures in place to reallocate that funding efficiently.
Like I feel like in order to defund the police,
we need to fund other things first.
And then we can just like build the pipeline so that there's money to go into
wherever we think is best. Like, I just worry that like,
if we were to defund the police,
now it would just like get thrown back into the government and then it would
just like go somewhere else to use it.
Um, so I say somewhat disagree because like in Houston,
I'm part of like the myrcene and leadership Alliance and something we've talked
about with the mayor of Houston is that he doesn't feel like the police should
be defended,
but he feels like the money that's in the police system right now should go
towards bringing other people into the system to actually handle the issues that
police are getting call for them, nothing to do with police, right.
Homelessness, mental health issues.
And so like when I did a lot of like research and looking at what other
democratic candidates feel like,
a lot of those people don't feel like there needs to be a defunding of the
police,
but more so I reform of the police structure and how they facilitate the
issue. So I don't think that defunding the police will lead to better policing.
I think for me after the aftermath of Ferguson, like,
which impacted my hometown, I just really having some questions, like,
why do they need tanks? Why do they need these grenades?
Why are they at war with us? And that, to me,
just made me take a step back with some of the equipment and resources that they
have from the military and Christie and I, I a hundred percent agree.
And I think when I support defending the police,
I support dismantling the police,
which is very different from abolishing the police,
even though people like to spin it as that. And to me,
there's already been enough police reform, especially since 2014,
we've got the cameras, we've got trainings,
but like there needs to be some sort of dismantling restructuring.
Or something because whatever is happening is not working.
But of course I would never say, get rid of the police,
but I definitely don't think that they need to have tanks,
especially if they're not doing implicit bias training.
I think defund the police like has such a bad connotation to it because it does
sound like this abrupt, like take away all their money,
but you can't fit a whole public policy plan into one slogan.
Some of the like top like brains in policy writing that
support defunding the police don't support just taking away all their funding
and doing nothing with it. And I think honestly,
if you reallocate the funds well enough,
we won't even need police at all eventually because why do police exist?
Because people are committing crimes.
Why does crime exist because of poverty because of, you know,
all these other reasons. So I think obviously not all at once,
but like if we gradually reallocate those funds into other resources,
we could get rid of a lot of the things that even require the need for police.
And maybe still have some law enforcement that exists,
but it will not be as big of a thing as it is now.
I think that is a very good point. That one,
a lot of these terms have like really strong connotations, right?
So like when Lisa dismantle, I was like, Jesus, like,
but like not even really like understanding the perception of this mantle that
she had. And so I think I really strongly agree that like,
when we say defund the police, where does that money go? Right.
Because in my head, when I hear defund the police,
I don't think that the police force is then going to take away their ability to
buy tanks and all these different things.
I immediately think that they're going to pay cops less. Right.
And that's what I think a lot of people think. Cause I, you know,
cause what does defund mean?
And so this is what concerns me because like this is anyone, right?
You get underpaid for something that you're really good at. And you're like,
excuse me. So I think that's a really good conversation to have.
I am open to conservative ideas,
Piper somewhat disagree, Leah agree.
Prinav somewhat agree. Benjamin agree, Chris,
somewhat disagree. Christine.
Strongly agree. There are some conservative ideals that I do respect, right?
Like I think that a lot of what this was down to is not
the issue itself, but the implementation of the issue,
like when I went to go look at the gun laws that, you know,
the Democrat parent candidates are looking at,
a lot of candidates are saying that we should, um, ban assault rifles.
And then most of them said that they're not going to buy them back.
And I'm like, okay, so we didn't prohibit this before.
So people spent X amount of dollars on this assault rifle and you're not at
least going to buy it back from them.
Another thing I think about is like the social welfare programs. Right.
Do I think more people should be eligible for it? Yes.
Is there any measure on a lot of these programs that get people off of the
system integrated back into the workforce? No.
So you have people who specifically take advantage of the system and
specifically take care of, take advantage of us as taxpayers.
I just, I think in life,
I'm just generally invested in just giving more food land crops, like money,
whatever it.
Is. There, there is plenty in the United States,
we have the infrastructure to support everyone in this country,
like significantly more than, than we do currently.
Warren's wealth tax is something that I was really, really in favor of.
And it's not something that those people are going to miss. Like it's not like,
like I'm like you're taking their livelihood from them.
You're simply repurposing a part of their livelihood that they're honestly
probably never going to get the opportunity to use in the first place and making
it so that other people can be at least, uh, a Slingshot closer.
So in that respect,
I think like conservative ideology tends to be stingier
if you will.
What America needs to do more is to compare itself to other countries and like
entities that have similar wealth, like in my political science class,
like we're comparing the United States to the European union countries in the UN
large,
like provide so many more social services to their people and their people are
so much happier and they're the wealth gap in America is
so much greater than it is there.
I'm always willing to hear what the other side has to say,
but like I'm pretty well versed in politics at this point. And like,
I know that like I honestly don't really agree with any conservative ideals.
I think for me, there can be like a lot of unlikely allies,
but I think it depends on what the outcome is of that conservative thinking.
Like whether or not I might be opening the listening to it. So like,
if they're like, okay, I really want to stimulate the economy.
We need more jobs. And then the,
how is through green jobs and green infrastructure,
like that's something that could definitely have bipartisan support.
Like I'm talking with a church that is really passionate and really wants to
take a bold stance on climate.
And if I would have just kind of shut them out because they do have some
conservative ideologies, then I feel like, you know,
maybe we wouldn't be able to, I guess, progress.
I don't want my ego to get so big where I think that the only way to be is
like me,
but that doesn't justify policies that lead to the oppression of other people.
That's another, that's another situation, but I can have empathy for, for them.
I believe Joe Biden.
We'll win this election. Somewhat agree,
somewhat agree. I agree. But this is me knocking on wood.
I agree. Strongly agree, agree.
I am not willing to let the universe think that I believe anything different
and I'm not willing to even let the words from my mouth escape to him, courage,
any kind of taking away from that outcome. Uh,
when I get super down in the dumps,
I go on Twitter to add Trump underscore regrets and to see posts from people who
are like, I can't believe I voted for you in 2016 and I'm voting for Biden now.
And I'm like, yeah, dude,
just to see like how many people have have defected and to even see the people
who hold themselves accountable in person, like looking now, they're like, Hey,
I thought, I thought maybe something different will be,
would be by switching it up and not sending a politician office in 2016.
I am so sorry. It makes me hopeful. Um, that like in the same way,
like a ton of people have defected from Trump.
I literally do not see the opposite at all.
Like I don't see anyone like who was like previously like Democrat and he's
like, you know what, it. I'm just going to vote for Trump.
Like no one is saying that, which is like, which makes me like very, very,
very happy.
I mean, it's I put some other because like, it depends, like,
it depends on us doing the work behind the scenes. So like make that happen.
Like elections aren't one. Cause like people get complacent. And so like,
I don't feel want people to think for a day between now and November 3rd that
like, we can take our foot off the pedal, but people are like, Oh,
Biden is up 15 points nationally. And I'm like, yeah,
Hillary was up like five points nationally. And what did that do for her?
Like we have to just keep working to make this happen.
It's what's going to be a fight like literally every single day from now until
election day.
Hi, y'all.